[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah for example I was flipping around I
was watching TV and I came across
stranger things that show stranger
things yeah love that show but I wasn't
sure you know I just was looking at it
for a second I didn't quite know what it
was when I first saw it so I hit the
button and it said a supernatural series
that takes place during a more innocent
time long before many of these child
actors will appear on Dancing with the
Stars just came up put they're helpful
yeah very helpful yeah I was watching
million dollar listing Los Angeles sure
million dollar listing Los Angeles
wasn't sure what it was we hit the
button and it said want to see what a
million dollars get you in Los Angeles
hope you like shitholes house of cards
I was watching house of cards I didn't
do it yet
this crowd was all over me I had done
nothing I know honey like look come on
come on yeah I was watching house of
cards and I hit the button and it said a
crazy fictional world where the Pres the
United States loses his job for being a
sexual harasser once upon a time on ABC
I was watching that show and then I hit
the info button it said watch this show
or I swear to god will cancel Modern
Family they're just skip my career I was
watching The Today Show and yeah
watching The Today Show and then I hit
the button it said if you're a male host
whose penis doesn't work please give us
a call
how are y'all doing me all good that's
good a Big Bang Theory it's watching the
Big Bang Theory
at the info button said nerds say nerdy
things you laugh because you're cooler
than them you watch the ads and buy the
products life goes on I was watching the
show this is us mm-hmm
yeah this is us I'm gonna hit the button
it said get the Kleenex ready that's
right you're going to want to masturbate
to this show yes what yeah I've never
seen that show oh boy
this audience is like maybe the smoke
outside ain't so bad well and finally I
was watching young Sheldon yeah watching
that show young Sheldon and then I hit
the button and it said or as Kevin
Spacey calls it exactly the right age
or the world what did you say I said
what a world what a world what a world
but if you can't say that at the end of
a comedy piece I just did all right
you